so it's my great honor to recognize this
year's recipients of the robert altman
award director and my friend fran crans
casting directors henry russell
bergstein and alison estrin and the
incredible cast kagan albright reed
bernie michelle n carter ann dowd jason
isaacs breda wall and the great martha
plimpton
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the great and out is watching us on
facetime so say hi to
[Applause]
anne hey thank you andrew
i learned so much
watching you from the wings
and uh spending time around that table
with you and mike and of course phil
i thought of that movie often or that
that time often when making this movie
so thank you this means even more coming
from you thank you
uh
wow thank you thanks first of all thank
you bleaker street for believing in us
and putting us in this incredible
position thank you
uh andrew
i've cherished our pep talks thank you
okay so i uh
i was kicked out of the venice film
festival's premiere of robert altman
shortcuts
uh i was 12 years old it's not like i
was drunk or anything but i um
my family was on vacation in italy my
dad somehow scored tickets to the
premiere and we went and then right
before the lights came down some usher
or someone at the festival was like
this is a kid he can't watch this and
they got rid of me and i was devastated
and thought it was very uneuropean of
them and i always sort of wondered who
is this robert altman guy and what could
possibly have been in that movie
and i saw it eventually
and i know exactly why they kicked me
out of there
but i also saw something else i saw a
new
definition and depth to the ideas behind
acting
and ensemble
i saw
how
different experience can somehow still
be shared human experience
and something at the core of this film
and i i i confirmed my suspicion that
robert altman and his films were among
the gold standard of what we all love to
do here and want to do here so thank you
film independent i know we'll cherish
this all of us this association our
whole lives
look it's not an easy film to celebrate
i wanted to demand a new kind of
attention on the pain and grief felt
around this country but also
the need to heal
the
i wanted to present a new way of looking
at one another seeing one another
speaking to one another
and how we might find some state of
grace in the process
all i can ask is that audiences watch
this movie
and ask themselves
what notions like truth reconciliation
and possibly even forgiveness look like
in their own lives in their communities
and their country
but
it is an award show and there are a
couple things that should be celebrated
in this movie that need to be celebrated
and thank you film independent for
shining just the right spotlight on this
film it is the perfect validation and it
belongs on the cast and the performances
thank you
that's right
henry allison
this movie was just not taken seriously
until you came on board i didn't even
take it seriously you breathe new life
into it you got gave me possibilities
and names and ideas that i could never
have imagined you changed the course of
this film and you changed the course of
my life so thank you thank you uh
rita michelle kagan this is the first
ensemble this movie does not work
without their work if it wasn't
recognized enough it certainly should be
recognized now the movie hinges on the
very delicate incredibly delicate place
they put the audience
it's beautiful work thank you guys i
love you guys
and then uh
last but not least
uh this is probably this is certainly
the last time i'll ever have a chance or
a platform like this to talk about these
four actors so i wanna i wanna go out
swinging and um
so first of all sorely missed martha
plimpton and anne dowd
yeah
and then these two right here jason
isaacs and reed bernie what these four
actors do yes
what they do individually but more
importantly collectively
is some of the most
open
raw selfless connected passionate
let's just be honest best goddamn acting
you'll ever see in your life
this is an ensemble for the ages thank
you guys i love you thank you so much
thank you
[Music]
you